Thank you.
Okay.
Why don't we start in on 645?
Unfortunately, there are more copies coming, but we're going to be working on what we had last week two weeks ago excuse me um and uh where we were at and is there any uh you know at that time we just felt that everybody wanted to have more time to absorb it and understand it and and get comfortable with it so i just want to make sure there is anybody has any other feelings or questions uh about it or are we ready to take action on it this is just a subcommittee right yeah so we don't do we have the do we have the amendment number No, we had this is we this was handed out.
Yeah, but 3 weeks ago or 2327 20.
2327.
Okay.
Carrie, do you want to talk about it?
No.
Yeah, we're doing 645 right now.
The Dow.
i think we should both be here okay can i make a comment yes keith i just want to make one comment to one way to think about this and i think representative spear you said this uh two weeks ago that these dowels are happening anyway, and this would – this isn't to allow a DAO to happen or not happen.
This is to, if they register with the state, to give them similar protections as limited liability as an LLC.
It also protects the state.
And that's important to the rest of us.
Exactly.
Right.
So this isn't to allow them.
This is to have them register.
That's some guardrails.
Okay.
So Representative Ammons, seconded by Representative Spears, moves ought to pass on the amendment.
Any discussion on the amendment?
Seeing in the no we have the business committee do i have each committee here okay the business and cole taxton mclears here no he hit a deer they are so unbelievable how much we have this year.
We got enough here.
We got enough.
Right, because we got Ammon, Cole, Hunt, and Herbert, and Spear.
And you can replace it it as the minority you can replace uh people actually know if you live in the accident crossed each other out but no with maculaire you can you'll replace macula for today for for now yeah okay all those in favor uh say yes uh yeah right.
All those opposed.
So that's one, two, three, four, five, and then to one.
What do you mean who the one is?
And he's on it.
He's on it.
No.
One, two, three, four, five, two, one.
And then we still have the exact one.
Right.
Okay.
You couldn't vote on this, John.
You're not on this committee.
I crossed him and Jackson and Sean out.
So I like pairing.
I don't like this replacement never have okay so that's 10 o'clock so the next one is 20 25 27 2327 23, 27, 23, 27.
Okay.
Okay, all right.
So now we're.
Waiting waiting until 10 45.
okay Thank you.
Thank you.
you okay Okay.
All right.
Okay.
Senate bill 82 is the 1st 1 I have here okay okay uh prompt payment for managed care and uh so i i have to admit i was very impressed with the department's presentation on the prompt payment issue um i will say that i did get an email from the commissioner on that if he really wanted us to get deeper into this thing, we could mandate that every step of the way that there would be notification.
and all I could think is cha-ching, cha-ching the cost of having the insurance companies have their software be notified.
all i could think is uh to ching to change the cost of of having a uh the insurance companies have their software be notifying the department for every step of the way and terming in terms of timing um so i i didn't go think too much more about that amendment but so um otherwise do we have any other comments anybody else have any comments this is the prompt pay and issue yeah yeah Okay, so I have Representative Terry making well to it.
This is a health committee.
So we got Terry Post, Broselli's not here.
on Calabro Vincent is this coming today have you heard okay and representative Gibbs is here is this coming today have you heard okay okay and representative gibbs is here and bros okay so um would anybody like to second the motion of inexpedient to legislate okay thank you all right any discussion on inexpedient to legislate all right seeing none all those uh on the health committee uh who agrees with the motion please say I I those opposed so moved unanimously so that's terry uh yeah uh gives girls yeah actually seven because we're we're missing a lot of people so and that didn't really replace them so it's technically four four to zip Excuse me.
seven because we're missing a lot of people so and that didn't really replace them so it's technically four four to zip excuse me no five to zip five zip what about seven seven seven seven seven okay all right seven out of eight okay oh okay all right everybody well I didn't see Perselli.
That's why.
No, post.
And then post.
Well, then it's six.
She's not here either.
Gee, okay.
So I'm not blind.
Well, you said five.
It's six.
So who says six?
Okay.
This is impressive.
We can't even count count that's why we're commerce we're not ways and means okay okay all right great next up is House Bill 303.
And I have not received any other amendments.
So Representative Calabro.
Moved to keep it in interim study.
Interim study.
Thank you.
And I will second that motion.
Any discussion on the motion of interim study?
All right.
How many people do I have in the room now?
All those in favor of interim study, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed?
So move unanimously.
Okay.
moved unanimously okay excellent yeah uh last but at least we have 11 30 at 11.35 to 279, right?
That's it right okay okay Subcommittees adjourned.
Thank you.
Okay.
We'll open up our final subcommittee here.
House Bill 279.
Can you hear me, Representative Spears?
Good.
Okay.
And we have the latest, greatest amendment that's been passed around.
And because even after the last one where we changed it, it turns out we had another little technical correction.
Am I looking at the right bill?
That ain't the right bill.
Okay.
So the key changes was that for the second offense, there's a minimum of 15 days by the maximum of 30.
And then the fine was at the same 7500 and then third offense is death now okay any questions from anybody so far everybody Everybody good?
Representative Patusek, seconded by Representative Burroughs, moves to pass on the amendment number 2421.
Any discussion on the motion?
All right.
Seeing none in the Liquor Committee, Subcommittee, we have.
Okay.
Patusek, Walsh, Hunt, Burroughs, Sullivan, and Bullio.
We're all here.
Gang's all here.
So all those in favor, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed?
So move unanimously.
Okay, motion now allowed to pass as amended.
Any discussion on the motion?
Okay.
All right, so Representative Patusek, seconded by Representative Burroughs, moves out to pass as amended.
Any discussion?
Seeing none.
All those in favor, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed?
So move unanimously.
Excellent.
Alright, so we're now adjourned until our session, which is scheduled 1 1.30?
Did I do it that late?
Oh, I guess I was worried about people wanting wanting people to talk.
Um Yeah, I I, I.
that that was i got an email from uh the house clerk saying that the calendar was going to close early and my fear was in case we didn't get something done that we would need next week so I wanted to get in in the calendar so so that that just leaves that possibility that you know if if we can't resolve it today then we have next week but but we I I was it's purely a backup you know it's Hopefully we'll never get to that place.
All right, so I'll see you all at 1.30 then.
Okay, and I'm still looking for volunteers for anything that somebody wants to make a motion on, so I don't have to make motion like the marijuana ones.
There must be some other people who want to make that motion.
Interim study of the last two.
either one to pick one right now if you look at the sheet you see my name is there way too much so i was willing to do it because honestly i'm on the commission but so is representative sullivan so maybe he would like to make the motion sure we need to keep it around to study it yeah we're just we're keeping around as vehicles all right of the two of them it said the house bill and then the senate bill okay all right how about condos do we have any don't anybody any democrats who have condos yeah there's one about there's one about the lanes yeah i think that should be okay all right so so you'll make them yeah this yeah that should be killed.
Okay.
All right.
So you'll make the – yeah.
This – yeah.
That's 178.
Yeah, 178.
And you're going to take that.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Yeah, they're okay.
No, no, we're in an interim study now.
And I really do believe the interim study is the right issue because to put it into a chapter study committee, which we hope senators will show up for in the second year, is no, they don't show up.
So this way, we, the committee, and all those ones who, you know, give us an opportunity for everybody to really understand because it's a very, it's a long story.
Right.
Okay.
All right.
So Chris, you'll do 178.
The condo leans.
Okay.
Great.
John.
And yeah, I said I would do 130 and 172.
Okay.
I have you for 130, 172.
Yes.
Thank Thank you.
okay great john and yep i said i would do 130 and 172.
okay i have you for 130 172.
yes thank you very much for doing that and uh no this is good and i i don't have a problem doing 239 because that's um representative almy's bill so it's probably better for me to do it so okay oh look who's here look at the cat dragon yeah the blur have the blurbs in the calendar?
Yeah, the blurbs would need to be done, you know, get them done tomorrow.
You know, get them, you know.
Yeah, if you get them done, that's great.
But yeah.
Okay.
stop i'm here i'm here folks you didn't do I'm in the middle of the great the great the great the great the great the great Yeah.
that and uh is Thank you.
Thank you.
okay we'll open up the exec session for the house commerce committee um i guess just to uh uh, bring to date so we have had a replacement uh since this past summer representative you has rejoined the commerce committee after his sabbatical and don't you sabbatical and course, unfortunately, we, uh.
Have a loss, uh, represent Macalier.
We had a deer.
So he's busy making making dinner for tonight.
I hope.
Oh, dear.
And so otherwise, we'll get through this, see how fast we can do this, right?
All right.
First up is House Bill 73.
three and...
I'd like to make a motion to move HB 73 relative to the repair of home appliances to interim study.
Interim study.
And second to that motion.
Representative Thackson.
and you're recognized to speak to that motion.
Representative Jackson and you're recognized to speak to your motion.
Excuse me.
It's just not ready at this point in time.
So interim study would be a good way to.
Kind of tease out all the issues with that bill.
Okay.
Yeah, Representative Burroughs.
Just before we vote, Sean Faleo asked me to say that he felt that we should target manufacturer's practice of canceling warranties if another repair works on the product.
That's entirely different legislation and would need a lot of input and research and input.
And he said I was the one who fought to save this bill from ITL, but at this point see it as unsavable.
So I just wanted to share that.
Okay.
So the motion is interim study.
Any more discussion on the motion?
Seeing none, the clerk will call the roll sorry are they all numbered interim study representative yes representative mcgugh mcHugh.
McHugh.
Yes.
Sorry.
Representative Patusick.
Yes.
Representative Terry.
Representative Post.
Yes.
Representative Cole.
Representative Pacelli.
Yes.
I hope Senator will...
representative yes yes representative waltz yes representative burrows yes representative herbert yes Yes.
Yes.
yes yes and all representative yes okay the motion is unanimous all those in favor, placing on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Those opposed.
So moved unanimously.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Are you okay?
I'm fine.
17, 17 to 1.
18 to 1.
We're missing 2, right?
Right.
No, we're missing 1.
We're only missing 1.
18 to 1.
Sorry, I didn't hear your vote sorry okay all right next up House Bill 86 relative to prohibiting the state from contracting with Chinese and so I I move inexpedient to legislate there's somebody else wants to do that motion somebody else want to do that ITL motion yeah okay do you need somebody to make the motion somebody want to make make the motion?
What the heck?
Yeah.
Okay.
Representative Speer, seconded by Representative Daxton, seconds the motion.
Let me speak to legislate.
Representative Speer is recognized to speak to her motion.
The purpose of this bill is mostly to keep the computers, for the state not to buy computers from the Chinese.
And we already have government legislation that does not allow that.
And the state government has already issued words to the effect that they're not allowed to do it.
So it's kind of overcome by events and it's not really required anymore yeah and the uh sponsor did call me and asked to kill the bill the sponsor called me and asked to itl the bill oh okay okay any more discussion on inkspeed the legislateate?
Seeing none, the clerk will call the roll.
Representative Ammon.
Yes.
Representative McGoo.
Representative Patusick.
Yes.
Terry.
Post.
Yes.
Cole.
Pacelli.
Yes.
Maxton.
Post yes Cole yes but jelly Yes Axton Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert yeah Clerk yes Um Molly no Howard molly Howard Howard Representative Vincent yes Galabra yes Gibbs yes and while I'm at it Can I ask everybody, please speak into the chat.
Gibbs.
Yes.
And while I'm at it, can I ask everybody, please speak into the microphone, because I can't hear you if you don't.
Okay.
Thank you.
Spear.
Yes.
Sullivan.
And Chairman Hood.
Yes.
All right.
Unanimous.
Okay.
yes and yes all right unanimous okay all those in favor of placing the house bill 86 on the consent calendar please say aye those opposed so moved unanimously yes yes okay next up is house bill 130 repealing the drug Yes.
Yes.
Okay.
Next up is House Bill 130, repealing the Drug Affordability Board.
Representative Spear, seconded by Representative Hunt, moves inexpedient to legislate.
On House Bill 130.
I'm so sorry.
I got lost there.
Right.
I moved to make it ITL.
And the reason for that is that it's been overcome.
It's already been, uh, allocated in the budget and has already been set up, so this bill is really not required anymore.
Perfect.
Any more discussion on the motion of inexpedient to legislate?
All right.
Seeing none, the clerk will call the roll and this is ito yep did people mind if i don't say representative it goes faster that way okay amon yes yes yes Terry yes Simon.
Yes.
Wigyu.
Matusik.
Yes.
Terry.
Post.
Yes.
Cole.
Pacelli.
Yes.
Saxton.
Walsh.
Yes.
Burrows.
Herbert.
Yes.
Burke.
Howard.
Yes.
Herbert.
Burke.
Yes.
Howard.
Vincent.
Yes.
Colabro.
Representative Gibbs.
Yes.
Spear.
And Sullivan.
Yes.
And Sullivan?
And Chairman Hyde?
Yes.
Okay, motion carries.
19 to zip.
All those in favor of placing on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed, so moved unanimously.
next bill uh house bill 173 relative to toilet facilities provided by restaurants okay you skipped 172.
oh i did oh i see i did that okay house bill 172 representative spearsed by Representative Hunt, moves inexpedient to legislate, and the comment is ditto to the previous bill.
Essentially, yes.
Okay.
Any more discussion on the motion?
Seeing none, the clerk will call the roll on House Bill 172.
Representative Speer, and I second it.
Okay.
Good.
All right.
And this is ITO?
Yep.
Salmon?
Yes.
Sigu?
Tusik?
Yes.
Terry?
Post?
Yes.
Cole?
Coach Terry.
Yes.
Post.
Cole.
Yes.
Coachelli.
Saxton.
Yes.
Walsh.
Burrows.
Yes.
Herbert.
Burke.
Yes.
Howard.
Vincent.
Yes.
Thank you.
yes Howard yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes Chairman Hunt.
19-0.
19 19 to zip all those in favor placing uh 172 on the consent calendar please say aye aye those opposed so move unanimously okay now 173 relative to toilet facilities provided by restaurants representative faxton seconded, seconded by Representative Burroughs, moves ought to pass on the amendment.
And let's see, our amendment number.
You know what?
You don't have the amendment?
I probably have it on my desk.
Okay.
This is the last amendment we had last couple weeks ago.
John will have it right John?
Probably in here somewhere.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
Okay.
So the amendment number is 2330.
And if all you might remember, this bill has one section and it repeals two rsas love it can't do any better you want to speak to your motion no you pretty well covered it basically zeros out an unnecessary section of the law right so it repeals 155 colon 40 and 155 41 if you're following along at home okay any discussion on the motion of ought to pass on the amendment seeing none the clerk will call the roll ammon yes thank you yes patoosic Terry.
Yes.
Post, yes.
The clear.
Nope.
Howard yes, Vincent.
Yes.
Clark yes the clear nope Howard yes Vincent yes yes Gibbs yes Spear yes Sullivan yes chairman hunt yes 19 to 0.
Motion passes.
A vote of 19 to zip.
All those in favour of placing 173 on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Aye.
Excuse me, was this?
This is on the amendment.
Amendment.
Okay, excuse me.
All right, motion is now.
Ought to pass as amended.
Blame it on the COVID.
All right, this is ought to pass as amended blame it on the cover all right this is not passed as amended 173.
ammon yes mcgill yes patoosic yes terry yes post yes cole yes richelli yes saxton yes walsh yes Post.
Yes.
Cole.
Rochelle.
Yes.
Saxton.
Walsh.
Yes.
Burrows.
Herbert.
Yes.
Clerk.
Howard.
Yes.
Vincent.
Calabro.
Yes.
Gibbs?
Spear?
Yes.
Sullivan?
And Chairman Hunt?
Yes.
Pass as amended.
Motion passes, nine to zip.
All those in favor of placing on the consent calendar please say aye aye those opposed so move unanimously okay next up hb 178 uh relative to enforcement of condo liens for assessments uh represent herbert moves any itl seconded by representative patousek and representative herbert is recognized to speak to his motion for condominium owners or associations to recoup lost rents.
And in the event of, you know, if we have a recession or something like that and a lot of people lose their jobs, the associations will be stuck.
They basically can't afford it.
So that's why I think it's not not a good bill Okay Any more discussion on the motion of inexpedient to legislate Seeing none the clerk will call the roll All right.
terry yes post yes cole yes rocelli yes maxton yes walsh yes burrows yes herbert yes bollier yes howard yes Vincent?
Yes.
Calabro?
Gibbs?
Yes.
Vincent?
Calabro?
Gibbs?
Yes.
Spear?
Sullivan?
Yes.
Chairman Hunt?
19 to 0.
Okay, motion to pass the vote, 19 to zip.
All those in favor of placing the bill on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed?
So moved unanimously.
Okay.
Next up is 225.
Relative to the prohibited use of currency that could be detrimental to privacy rights.
And I believe the subcommittee did interim study.
So who do I have?
Representative Ammon.
Seconded by Representative Burroughs.
Okay.
Seconded by Representative Patusek moves interim study and Representative Ammon is recognized to speak to his motion.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I believe this bill was attempting to address central bank digital currencies, which is something that at least a few dozen countries are pursuing.
I think at this time it's too early to know exactly how to legislate one way or the other but the issue will keep coming back i think there has been another bill filed in the subject area that we'll be dealing with probably on this committee so i recommend interim study to keep it alive and have some future discussion about it other discussion on the motion of interim study for hospital 22 225?
Representative Spear.
Three comments.
The state of Florida has attempted to do this, but in a slightly different fashion, and they passed the bill.
And in the, and I have a copy of it here, and in the FN for that bill, it says, if the Federal Reserve ever decides to issue a central bank digital currency that applies to the public, this bill will be considered unconstitutional.
We don't know what this central bank digital currency will look like.
We're putting in a law on the books for something we have no idea what it looks like.
In addition to that, the Federal Reserve has issued a paper describing what's involved.
And in order to issue a public bank, a public version of a bank currency, it would take the place essentially of the local banks.
95% of people in this country already have relationships with their banks.
And they said, the Federal Reserve said that unless a law is passed, it would cost them hundreds of millions of dollars to issue such a public currency.
So the point of what I'm trying to say here is we're putting a law on the books that is both unconstitutional and we don't know what the Federal Reserve even looks like, and we don't know what the law should be.
This law does not belong to be – it shouldn't be – Right, but we're not passing anything.
All we're doing is studying it and to see if there is some way that you could do it constitutionally, A, or B, whether this is just not necessary and when we don't need this bill.
I made my comment.
That's what I got to say about it.
Okay.
Do whatever you want.
Well, you know what I really want is I want it just to go interim study and we put it on the consent calendar and call it a day.
Okay.
That's what I really want.
I'm so sorry.
Interim study goes on the consent calendar?
if we vote for it but if if you were able to convince a large chunk of people here to go with not passing an interim study motion then we would have to uh have to have it on the regular calendar yeah we don't have to speak on it but it gives us the opportunity to speak yeah i know i just i just no i understand i made my comments that's all i do.
So let this thing disappear on the consent calendar.
There's another bill coming.
Okay.
All right.
Representative Ammon, you have a comment?
I was just going to say there's another bill filed by – so we'll have to talk about this all over again.
That's a good point, what you just said.
So the governor signed an executive order.
I've talked about this before.
He created a cryptocurrency digital asset commission.
We met for a year.
We had a final report.
And in that final report, I put a statement about central bank digital currencies.
This is before any of these bills were filed.
And it was just to make people aware of it, not necessarily to act on legislation.
But somebody's trying to act on it, right?
Yeah, but we're going to study it.
Right.
We're're going to keep the issue around, but not act on it.
I have the problem with the word detrimental.
That's only one of the words you have a problem with.
Just to start, so to me, yeah, but so in terms of really trying to fully understand what the issue here is, that idea that could there actually be a currency in which the government gets to know everything you're doing with that transaction and that currency.
Yeah, let me say, every bill has a grain of truth.
This has a grain of truth that does sound a little scary to me, that government could track my currency transaction.
The purpose of it is to track.
Okay?
And I certainly would never want my government to be doing that.
I definitely disagree with you on that.
I absolutely disagree.
Okay.
You think that's a good idea, that government can track your transactions?
I think that, first of all, banks do track every single thing that you do already.
But I do not believe that that is the intent of a central bank digital currency at all.
And if you go to the Federal Reserve website, words one after the other tell you that is not what they want to do.
And they don't want to do this at all.
They don't even want to do it because it's going to cost hundreds of millions of dollars to do it.
And they don't want to spend the money.
So we're legislating against something that isn't going to happen.
And if it ever did, we don't know what it is.
And if we outlawed it, it would be against the Constitution anyway.
We're far from passing this bill.
We're far, far away.
All right.
I've said my set.
Okay.
Any more discussion on the motion of interim study?
Right.
See none will call the roll all right ammon yes thank you yes patusick yes terry yes post yes cole yes pocelli yes faxton yes Walsh yes burrows no herbert no clerk no um howard no vincent i wish i could say maybe I can't, so I'll just say yes.
Labro?
Yes.
Gibbs?
No.
Spear?
There are a few of us that want to IDL.
I just want this bill to go away.
Sullivan.
I'm tempted to say yes.
You can say what she wants to say, but you do have to make an answer.
Really?
You do say yes or no yes you do have to you can't have seen you missed that opportunity walking out of the room i know and i if i wasn't so silly i would have realized what was happening okay so what's the what's the vote believe it or not i'm gonna say yes because i'm'm an idiot.
All right.
Sullivan.
Yes.
I'm sorry.
Chairman.
Yes.
All right.
So you guys don't want to change your votes.
You can change your vote.
14 to 5.
And we'll leave that on the regular calendar.
Okay.
Yeah.
Would there be a minority report?
Okay.
Start up trouble.
No, that's fine.
That's fine.
Okay.
Start up trouble.
No, that's fine.
That's fine.
Okay.
House Bill 227 relative to fair access to financial services.
Can we ITL this one?
John, you don't like it either.
Nobody likes this bill.
So ITL moved by Representative Bollier and seconded by Sullivan.
ITL.
When are you saying ITL?
I'll second that.
Wait a minute.
We were going to have Persella was going to do an interim study.
Well, we made the motion.
You did?
Did I?
This COVID thing makes me really deaf sometimes.
Kirk made the motion.
I have my speaker on.
Hold on.
My mic.
Okay.
What motion was made and seconded first?
Motion ITL was moved and seconded by Sullivan.ivan was that the motion on the floor then i guess so all right that's fine yes you can all right well first who said made the motion with sullivan myself oh you made the motion this is impressive i'm i'm uh okay all right well we won't let this happen again okay representative bullio is recognized to speak to our motion i never liked esgs i don't like the conversation that's been going on for four years now, and I just refuse to pass any bill recommending that the banks have to follow ESG rules.
Chairman Hunt?
Yes.
Again, could I ask that everybody speak into the microphone rather than turning their heads to address somebody else?
Please speak to everybody.
It's very confusing.
Thank you.
Chairman Hunt?
Yes.
Again, could I ask that everybody speak into the microphone rather than turning their heads to address somebody else?
Please speak directly.
It's very confusing.
I'm sorry.
Listen to Representative Salah.
Yeah.
No, so this was a – I'm kind of surprised that this is actually as controversial as it is on this committee because I know that many on this committee from the opposing party of mine is are not supportive of this i mean we're basically saying to banks what they can and cannot consider when they're running their business and that just fundamentally goes against everything i believe in it goes in everything that a lot of other people in this committee believe in i think uh they came back with a slight tweak in their amendment but even so it it, it still hamstrings various banks if they want to change their business model.
It would be hard to do that.
I mean, just why are we in the business, why are we as a legislature in the business of telling banks what they can and cannot consider when they're making a loan or conducting business with people?
We already have federal statutes that prevent discrimination and banking against things like race or gender or religion.
But beyond that, I think if you want to have a special niche that focuses on ESG things, that's fine.
If you want to have a special niche that focuses on oil and gas drilling companies, that's fine.
I don't think we should make laws prohibiting either.
And this is a law to prohibit one type of thing that is offensive to certain types of people who have certain worldviews.
And I don't think we should take a stance on that.
I think we should let the market do its job, which is to let the businesses, the banks, run the businesses how they want to run it.
And I think it's kind of crazy that we're trying to get involved in this.
Well said.
Representative Ammon.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
And I don't disagree with anything the previous speaker just said.
The history of this bill last term, the Senate turned it into a study commission that was supposed to happen.
And what they did was they said the first named Senate member calls the first meeting and they never called the meeting.
So they never actually had the study commission.
So that's why I would be in favor of an alternate motion of interim study, just so that the subject matter is given its due, the market operates best with the most information, and maybe we could figure out exactly what's happening here, you know, in the meantime, and that information could inform the market to, you know, to be more, you know, to operate more optimally.
So that would be my alternate motion.
Okay, so the reason why I wanted to interim study it is that this is an issue that is ongoing.
It's being talked about by a lot of states.
And I like the opportunity for us to always keep the option open where we can keep a bill around that some of us find is controversial.
Some of us say it would be a cold day in hell that we'd ever vote for it.
But at the same time, we want to make sure we understand the issue, understand what the people who are concerned about the issue.
And so that we have an opportunity to place where we can have that conversation.
And Lord knows there's some other bills on this that have the same situation, guys.
Okay.
And that's why it was interim study.
It said we're just, you know, I understand, you know, that you can't really get behind its piece of truth to it, but the fact is that there have been stories where people have accused of financial institutions not giving a loan simply because of the nature of the business and and so if that is true then we should at least be looking into it no the bank is supposed to tell you why they're opposed to it so I the pending motion is ITL and the clerk will call the roll.
Ammon.
No.
Hugh.
Tusik.
No.
Terry.
Post.
No.
Cole.
Pacelli.
No.
Baxton.
Wals No.
No.
Yes.
.
howard yes vincent yes collabro yes gibbs yes spear yes sullivan yes chair no okay representative porcelli second by represent amin moves an interim study could we have the results first please oh i'm sorry 10 to 9.
9 yes 10 nays okay All right.
Representative Porcelli.
10 nays.
Okay.
All right.
Representative Porcelli, seconded by Representative Ammon, moves interim study.
Any discussion on the motion?
Wait a minute.
This, I don't know.
ITL failed failed it now takes another vote.
You got to have a prevailing.
All right.
Interim study interim study.
Thank you.
All right.
Yes.
Thank you.
I'm sorry.
yes mcgugh yes patusick yes terry yes host yeah cole yes bachelli yes faxton yes walsh yes burrows no herbert no clerk no howard no vincent no colabro no gibbs no spear no sullivan no chairman hunt yes Thank you.
Gibbs no spear no Sullivan no chairman hut yes okay will there be a minority report sure all right okay and the motion is ideal and your yeah your motion will be itl yeah yeah okay moving right along uh 239 relative condominium disclosure of financial information.
Okay.
What do I have here?
I move inexperienced to legislate.
And second by Representative Patusek.
So, the intent of this bill by the sponsor was to require all condos to have to get to audited financials.
And requiring audited financials is a very expensive tool, as some of you might know if you've been in business you know that getting a full full audit is a huge cost and um obviously there was no uh change the size of the condo or really need the condo or and you know you're basically you want to force the condo have to do it even though they don't see that they have a financial problem so at this point I think this bill should be inexpedient to legislate and who motioned I made the motion and representative Ptussek second Is there any discussion on the motion?
Okay.
Clerk will call the roll.
Ammon.
Yes.
McGue.
Matusik.
Yes.
Terry.
Post.
Yes.
Cole.
Pacelli.
Yes.
Thaxton.
Walsh.
Yes.
Burroughs.
Herbert.
Yes.
Clark.
Howard.
Yes.
Vincent.
Collabro.
Yes.
Gibbs.
Spear.
Yes.
Sullivan.
Chairman Hunt.
Yes.
19-0.
All those in favor of placing on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed to the consent calendar, please say aye.
in favor of placing on the consent calendar please say aye aye those opposed so moved unanimously okay next up is House bill 242 relative to banning PFAS in FOOD AND PACKAGING.
REPRESENTATIVE SPEAR.
RIGHT.
I GUESS WE'RE LEAVING IT AT IS INTERIM STUDY.
YES, WE ARE, AREN'T WE NOW?
YOU'VE GOT SO MANY PAPERS HERE AND THEY'RE ALL DIFFERENT ORDERED.
I'M SORRY.
OKAY.
AND I SECOND THE MOTION.
AND REPRESENTATIVE SPEER, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK TO YOUR MOTION.
THIS BILL IS GOING TO BE OVERCOME.
THIS ALONG WITH ANOTHER BILL THAT WE'RE GOING TO VOTE ON HAS BEEN OVERCOME BY A BILL THAT'S COMING UP IN THE NEXT SESSION THAT INCORPORATES BOTH ASPECTS OF BOTH BILLS IN A WAY THAT MATCHES THE MODEL LEGISLATION THAT'S BEING THAT HAS been the that's coming up in the next session that incorporates both aspects of both bills in a in a way that matches the model legislation that's be that has been developed by new moa so we have a much better uh organized shot uh if you will for a legislation that makes sense and maybe you want to tell everybody who new moa is i'm I'm sorry?
NUMOA.
NUMOA, what is it?
Oh, that's the New England...
Does somebody know what that stands for?
Multi...
Multi-state.
Oh, the NUMOA is a group of waste managers...
Solid waste managers for...
That includes a number of states, and they make model legislation that tries to keep various chemicals out of the solid waste landfills so that we don't pollute our groundwater and other environmental aspects of our life.
And we know this because they do the mercury.
that's how we found them okay any more discussion on the motion of uh uh interim what do we interim study interim study for 242.
seeing none the clerk will call the roll ammon yes thank you yes Yes.
Tusek.
Yes.
Terry.
Host.
Yes.
Cole.
Rochelle.
Yes.
McGill.
Tusick.
Yes.
Terry.
Post.
Yes.
Cole.
Rochelli.
Yes.
Paxton.
Walsh.
Yes.
Burroughs.
Herbert.
Yes.
Burke.
Howard.
Yes.
Vincent.
Labro.
Yes.
Gibbs.
Spear.
Yes.
Labro?
Gibbs?
Yes.
Speer?
Sullivan?
Yes.
Chairman Hunt?
Motion carries a vote of 19 to Zib.
All those in favor of placing on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed, so move unanimously.
Okay.
Next up, House Bill 279, increasing the penalty for on-premise licensees over serving alcohol.
Representative Patusek, seconded by Representative Burroughs, moves out to pass on Amendment 2421.
And Representative Patusek is recognized to speak to his motion.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
The Amendment 2421H clarifies a lot of the questions that were originally in HB 279, and I move OTP on the amendment.
Okay.
Any other discussion on the motion?
Seeing none, the clerk will call the motion.
There's a lot to pass as amended.
On the amendment.
Excuse me.
279.
Ammon.
Yes.
McGue.
Matusik.
Yes.
Terry.
Post.
Yes.
Cole.
Michelli.
Yes.
Taxton.
Walsh.
Yes.
Burroughs.
Herbert.
Howard yes Vincent yes Calabro yes Gibbs yes Spear yes Sullivan yes Jim and Hunt yes 19 to 0.
Okay, 19-6.
The motion now is ought to pass as amended by Representative Patusek.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I move HB 279, OTP as amended.
The amendment does become the bill.
So I move that as OTPA.
Okay.
Any more discussion on the motion about to pass as amended clerk will call the roll amin yes mcgill yes patusick yes terry yes post yes cole yes Richelli yes Saxton yes Walsh yes Burroughs yes Herbert yes yes Howard yes Vincent yes Collabro?
Yes.
Gibbs?
Spear?
Yes.
Sullivan?
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes 19 to zero.
19 to zip.
There's a part of me that feels like we should keep this on the regular calendar because of the fines.
I don't know No, I just All right, all those in favor placing on the consent calendar say aye.
I suppose so moved unanimous Okay So moved unanimous.
Okay.
All right.
HB 303, relative to insurance coverage for pain management services.
I would like to move that we keep this an interim study.
The sponsors for this bill and I are going to be working with people in the next coming months to try and get this up to where it should be but we may have brought some stakeholders together that may obviate the need for this bill altogether thank you okay any other discussion on the interim the motion for hb 303 seeing none the clerk will call the roll she moved collaborative moved seconded by Patusek Ammon.
Yes.
McGue.
Matusik.
Yes.
Terry.
Post.
Yes.
Cole.
McGue.
Yes.
Patusick.
Terry.
Yes.
Post.
Cole.
Yes.
Pacelli.
Baxton.
Yes.
Walsh.
Burroughs.
Yes.
Herbert.
Clear.
Yes.
Howard.
Herbert Clark.
Yes.
Vincent.
Calabro.
Yes.
Gibbs.
Spear.
Sullivan.
Yes.
Chairman Hunt.
19-0.
All those in favor of placing on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Those opposed?
So move dynamically.
Okay.
HB 319, establishing a committee to study an all-payer system of insurance for hospital services.
Representative Ammon second by representative burroughs moves uh inexpedient to legislate and representative amin is recognized to speak to his motion yeah so this would be another study committee to study all pair for insurance for hospital services.
I think through the discussion, both testimony and among the subcommittee that, you know, we decided that this was not appropriate to move forward with.
And so for that reason we move ito okay any discussion on the motion seeing none the clerk will call the roll ammon yes mcgill yes Yes.
Tusek.
Yes.
Terry.
Post.
Yes.
Cole.
Pacelli.
Yes.
Baxton.
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes Collabro?
Yes.
Gibbs?
No.
Spear?
Yes.
Sullivan?
And Chairman Huck?
Yes.
18 to 1.
Representative Gibbs, would you vote okay with putting this on the consent calendar?
Yes.
Okay.
All those in favor and consent, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed?
Okay.
All right.
House Bill 373, relative to billing for ambulance services.
No, you skipped one.
353.
Oh, okay.
Sorry.
Oh, I see what I did.
I see what I did.
Okay.
353, establish an interstate compact for universal health care.
And Representative McGill, you're going to take this one.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I'd like to move an expedient to legislate on 353.
Okay.
And you're recognized to speak to your motion.
Seconded by Representative Patuzek, you're recognized to speak to your motion.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
This bill would have created a single-payer system in the form of a interstate compact in New Hampshire.
I see no viable source of funding in the bill either.
Certainly needs a little more work and it's probably not the right time for this bill the the bill also relies on neighboring states creating similar interstate compacts with the intent that we would join those and join a national single-payer health care system so for those reasons i urge you to vote itl okay any other discussion on the motion of inexpedient to legislate seeing none the clerk will call the roll ammon yes thank you yes patoosic yes terry yes post yes cole yes bachelli yes faxton yes walsh yes burrows yes herbert yes Yes.
Cole.
Yes.
Coachelli.
Baxton.
Yes.
Walsh.
Burrows.
Yes.
Herbert.
Burke.
Yes.
Howard.
Vincent.
Yes.
Labro.
Gibbs.
Spear.
Yes.
Sullivan.
Chairman Hunt.
Yes.
18 to 1.
Okay.
All those in favor of placing on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed?
So moved.
Okay.
House Bill 373 relative to billing for ambulance services.
I'd like to make a motion to ITL.
Okay.
House Bill 373 relative to billing for ambulance services.
I'd like to make a motion to ITL.
Okay.
Representative Burroughs, seconded by Representative Patusek, moves in expedient to legislate.
And Representative Burroughs is recognized to speak to our motion.
Yes.
This bill has been rendered unnecessary because there's been a committee formed by the insurance commissioner with the stakeholders involved in this issue.
So that committee and the commissioner feel that this is not a legislative issue, and I feel this bill is no longer necessary.
Okay.
Any more discussion on the motion of inexperience to legislate?
Seeing none, the clerk will call the roll ammon yes mcgill yes matusick terry yes post yes cole yes richelli yes taxton yes walsh yes burrows Burroughs.
Yes.
Herbert.
Clark.
Yes.
Howard.
Vincent.
Yes.
Blabrow.
Gibbs.
Yes.
Spear.
Sullivan.
Yes.
And Chairman Hunt.
19 to 0.
All those in favor of placing it on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed, so move to Hamsley.
Okay.
383, relative to provider contract standards for pharmacy benefit managers.
Representative Patusek, seconded by Representative Burroughs, moves to legislate.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
Mr.
Chairman.
I move ITL on HB 383 relative to provide contract standards for PBMs.
A very complex subject and it's just another law that we don't really need okay it's a little bit more than that.
But anyways, this was the issue that the pharmacies wanted to know if they, why can't they, you know, where can they get it cheaper?
And so that they were not being shortchanged on how much it would cost them to buy drugs.
And clearly the PBMs are able to buy it cheaper than the independent pharmacists can.
I just want to add that I think some of the larger pharmaceutical companies are going bankrupt because of this issue, the PBMs.
Yeah.
I don't know that Rite Aid is going because of PBMs.
I think Rite Aid is going bankrupt because they took out huge loans that they couldn't get too many locations.
And their debt service was overwhelming.
Well, there are some pharmacies.
But, okay, that is your entitled to your opinion.
Right.
Representative Spear.
I did a lot of research on this one to find out what states had this law, and there were a bunch of states that do.
But this law by itself doesn't do the answer.
It needs to have a bunch of other things that go with it, and we could go through that someday, but this law by itself won't do it.
So that's why I think we need to really ITL it, and if somebody wants to do something in the future that it needs to be more comprehensive if we want this to work okay all right so the motion is in the experience to legislate oh thank you okay clerk will call the roll all right amin yes mcqueue yes patoosic oh yes terry yes post yes cole yes picelli yes faxton yes walsh yes burrows yes herbert Yes.
Herbert.
Yes.
Howard.
Vincent.
Yes.
Gibbs.
Sullivan.
Yes.
Chairman.
19 to 0.
Okay.
All those in favor of placing on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed, so move unanimously.
Okay.
All right.
House Bill 414, relative to health insurance coverage for preventative PFAS care?
I make motion to I move the motion of ITL as we do not need this bill because we have two other bills coming which will be more comprehensive.
Well that's the other PFAS bills, but yes, this one, sorry, I gave you bad advice.
Okay.
Yeah, so 414 is, this was the insurance companies who are already providing the services.
Sorry, you asked me about it, and I gave you the wrong answer.
That's my fault.
Yes, Representative Speer.
The bill was based on a 300-page study that was submitted to the CDC, and the idea was the hope that that would have been adopted by the CDC.
Since the CDC did not adopt it, we can't make the insurance companies adopt something that wasn't approved by the CDC, and that's why we don't want the bill.
All said.
Thank you.
At least somebody does their homework here.
Yeah.
Hey, I read my car manuals.
Okay.
All right.
So the motion is inexperienced to legislate.
Any more discussion on the motion?
Seeing see none the clerk will call the roll all right and this is ITO on 4 414 all right Ammon yes McHugh yes Tusek yes Terry yes post yes Cole yes Pacelli.
Yes.
McHugh.
Tusick.
Yes.
Terry.
Post.
Yes.
Cole.
Pacelli.
Yes.
Paxton.
Walsh.
Yes.
Burroughs.
Herbert.
Yes.
Burke.
Howard.
Yes.
Vincent.
Calabro.
Yes.
Gibbs.
Spear.
Yes.
Sullivan.
Chairman Hunt.
Yes.
19 to 0.
Okay.
All those in favor for consent, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed, so moved unanimously.
Okay.
Okay, next up is 465, restricting Use of PFAS Substances in Certain Consumer Products.
Representative Spear.
Right.
The motion is to interim study this because, and for the same reason as HB 242, we have another bill that's coming along in the next session that will codify both bills together.
And so this bill isn't really needed anymore.
Okay.
Any more discussion on the interim study motion?
Who seconded it?
Me.
Okay.
Clerk will call the roll.
Ammon.
Yes.
McGill.
Satusick.
Yes.
Terry.
Post.
Yes.
Cole.
Pacelli.
Yes.
Maxton.
Walsh.
Yes.
Burrows.
Herbert yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes hunt yes 19 to zero okay motions uh those in favor of placing 465 on the consent calendar please say aye aye those opposed so moved unanimously okay uh house bill 513 relative to the affordability and safety of clinician Administrativeministrated drugs.
Representative McGue, moves interim study, seconded by Representative Hunt.
Representative McGue, you'll recognize to speak to your motion.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I was the prime sponsor on this bill.
There was a great deal of confusion.
It started out addressing white bagging and brown bagging.
The conversation evolved into discussing methods of billing for pharmacy, for pharmaceuticals under medical versus pharmacy.
Need some more time to work on.
I'll be happy to work on it, and I'd appreciate the interim study.
Okay.
Any more discussion on the motion?
Seeing none, the clerk will call the roll.
Interim study.
Ammon.
Yes.
McHugh.
Patusick.
Yes.
Terry.
Coase.
Yes.
Cole.
Procelli.
Yes.
Max those in favor of placing the bill on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed, so move unanimously.
House Bill 544, legalizing cannabis for retail sale.
I'd like to make a motion for interim study.
Okay.
Representative Burroughs moves out interim study, seconded by Representative Sullivan.
Representative Burroughs, you're recognized to speak to your motion.
Yeah.
There is a commission.
There's a new commission this year that is studying marijuana, and there has been another bill introduced that will be introduced next year.
But I think it's a good idea to keep the conversation open about cannabis because I believe it's really time that we legalize it in New Hampshire.
We're losing revenue, and we desperately need cannabis gummies in the Statehouse.
Oh, my God.
we're losing revenue and we desperately need cannabis gummies in the in the state house oh my god please don't make me pee in a cup okay oh boy all right all right uh the motion is uh interim interim study on house bell 544 the clerk may call the roll Ammon yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes walsh yes burrows yes herbert yes clerk yes howard yes vincent puff puff yes collabro yes gibbs yes spear yes sullivan yes and chairman hunt yes Gibbs Speer Sullivan Chairman Hunt Yes Okay, motion passes All those in favor Placing on the consent calendar, please say aye Those opposed So move unanimously Okay, last House bill Relative to the establishment of a decentralized autonomous organizations as legal entities within the state.
And Representative Ammon, seconded by Representative Burroughs, moves to pass on the amendment number 2327.
Representative Ammon is recognized to speak to his motion.
Thank you, Mr you mr chair so we retained this bill to do further work over the summer and the amendment before us is the result of that it's a replacement of the bill beginning with the language of the original bill but it does a full uh replace after the enacting clause and this is a a product of consulting with the Department of Revenue, the Banking Department, the Secretary of State's office, and other experts to try to resolve some of the questions that came up.
Representative Filio asked a bunch of really helpful questions in the original testimony.
And so this is the end result of that so the the internet has allowed us to communicate in in brand new ways and and a a dow based on blockchain technology allows us to organize in brand new ways and that's what a dow allows for and it does so in a transparent way um so this bill would would legally recognize d, and it could attract positive economic activity to our state.
Other states have done something similar, Utah most recently, and it instructs the Secretary of State to implement a registry so that the state would be able to register the activity of these DAOs just like they do with LLCs and other corporations.
This doesn't allow for DAOs to be created.
They're already being created.
This just allows for the DAOs, entices them to register with the state for legal protections, as long as they don't violate any of the rules that are in this amendment.
So I ask for all to pass on the amendment.
Great.
I just want to make a comment on the FN.
Are you, are you fine with that?
There's a note, financial note.
Yeah, but that, that would have been based on the original bill.
So there's still, there's no FN on it?
Who knows?
If you have to pull up the original bill and see what the FN was.
So there'll be discussions.
I'm just going to give you a preview.
If it passes, there'll be discussions in the Senate about tweaking that to make sure that it's covered for the Secretary of State's office.
Will that be a tax or a fee?
No, it'll be fee-based.
It'll be fee-based.
I thought a fee was a tax.
No, no.
It's a user fee.
You pay so well good attention on the house.
So you only pay for it if you're using the service, just like you do with a corporation.
Wow.
All right.
And wouldn't charge you here.
Yeah.
So again, this would be optional for DAOs.
If DAOs want to have the protections in this bill, they would sign up for it, but DALs are being created all over the place at this time on the Internet right now.
Okay.
Any more discussion on the motion of ought to pass on the amendment to House Bill 645?
Seeing none, the clerk will call the roll.
Ammon.
Yes.
Hugh.
Patusick.
Yes.
Terry.
Seeing none, the clerk will call the roll.
Clark no Howard yes Vincent yes yes yes yes yes yes all right 17 to 17 to 2 the motion is now represent Ammonmon, seconded by Representative Burroughs, moved off to pass as amended.
Is there any discussion on the motion?
Seeing none, the clerk will call the roll.
Okay.
Not pass as amended.
All right.
Ammon.
Yes.
Osborne.
All right.
Ammon.
Yes.
Osborne.
I mean, McHugh.
Yes.
Tusek.
Terry.
Yes.
Post.
Cole.
Yes.
Pacelli.
Axton.
Yes.
Walsh.
Burroughs.
No.
Herbert.
Clark.
No.
Howard.
Yes.
Vincent.
Calabro.
Yes.
Gibbs.
Spear.
Yes.
Sullivan.
Chairman Hunt.
Yes.
17 to 2.
Okay.
would there be a minority report this makes my third one right on the same subject we can do a four foot if you want yeah i get you got it after crypto uh yeah i'll do a minority.
Yeah.
Okay.
We'll leave that on the regular calendar.
I think that's good for the regular calendar anyways.
Okay.
We have four Senate bills, and we're on our home stretch here.
Establishing a study committee on residential-owned manufactured housing park disputes and oversight of resident-owned manufactured housing parks.
I'd like to make a motion.
Okay.
Interim study.
Representative Burroughs, seconded by Representative Hunt, makes a motion of interim study.
Representative Burroughs is recognized to speak to our motion.
Yeah, I do want to speak to this.
I think this is an issue of a lot of importance to many of our constituents, some of whom are here today.
And I know that there are quite a number of us on the committee that want to seriously study this and look for a solution.
And I just also, I was asked to tell you that Chris McAleer wanted to be here today, but he hit a deer and he could not be here.
But he really is here to support you.
So thank you.
Representative Gibbs.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I just want to add that I've received a lot of contacts, emails and phone calls from residents of manufactured home parks urging support of this bill.
Okay.
All right.
Is the motion clear in interim study?
Clerk will call the roll.
Thank you.
clerk will call the roll all right ammon yes mcgugh yes patoosic yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes spear yes sullivan yes chairman haunt yes 19 to 0.
19 zip all those in favor of placing on the consent calendar please say aye aye those opposed so moved unanimously senate bill 82 relative to prompt payments for managed care terry representative terry moving uh the last i knew uh moving uh moving an expedient to legislate in the interim mr chairman i have received a copy of a proposed amendment on my desk today.
Can you explain how this factors in?
No.
That was a different – is that really this bill?
Amendment to SB 82?
Oh, that one.
Yeah.
No, that – that accidentally got put out.
But, no, I do not support that amendment.
No.
This is the amendment where I said – This amendment with your name on it, you do not support it.
I'm just trying to understand.
Okay.
I was surprised that it got distributed, but it could have.
This is a mistake.
Yeah, okay.
It was a mistake.
Okay.
If we could rewind the tape and omit that.
Mr.
Chairman, okay.
As you may recall, for all of those kids who are home from school now and watching on YouTube, we received a marvelous presentation from the Department of Insurance with 20 pages of slides that were put together as a handout.
In living color.
my understanding with the notes that i took that day which would have been the 17th of october that there was that was we were waiting for a draft bulletin by the insurance department do we know before i go on if that draft has been uh that's That's a different bill, isn't it?
Final decision.
Let's see.
Is this another one um no i think that was that was the man on this one that was the mental health one the bulletin okay there was only a mental um no a bulletin yeah the mental health All right, so okay, so scrap that as I understand it the the issue here was with respect to a to reconsiderations of claims that had some sort of problem in that there was a by statute there's a 45-day period during which the reconsideration process is to be completed.
Now, the problem that we heard is that not all of those issues are being resolved within the 45-day period.
nevertheless the way understand the, and I hope this is the final iteration of the bill that we had, was that if in fact the claim was not sent on to the next wicket in 45 days, that it must be considered as a clean claim and it has to be paid.
So the problem that we had as we really dove down into this was that there are multiple issues that could be at work with respect to what is going on within the 45-day time frame.
And so because the statute, the bill does not indicate that the claim may be paid, which of course means nothing, because if it may, it may not, and has no binding force, and that the word shall is retained, that this does not foresee or provide for any of the extenuating circumstances that were identified.
For that very reason, we believe it would be imprudent to enact this bill as it was presented to us.
And for that reason, the issue does not go away.
The issue not resolved but this is not a not the appropriate way to handle this given all that we heard and therefore um looping back uh yes mr chair i move ITL on SB 82.
Are you seconded by hon?
Sure.
Okay.
Any discussion on the Any discussion on the motion?
Only to say that I thought this was an extraordinarily complicated issue and that the insurance department should be called out for assisting us greatly in coming to a better understanding of this.
Some of us coming from a fairly low point on the learning curve and having come to such clarity with respect not only to the process, which is very, very long and complicated, but in addition to identifying the real issues that are at work here and how difficult this is going to be to resolve thank you yeah and I remember just um the insurance division just saying that you know they can be phoned I mean they can they can have a you know conversation um and try to resolve it uh in in that way if they can or just more clarity like yes yes okay any more discussion on the motion seeing none the clerk will call the roll it on SB 82 Ammon yes thank you yes Tusek.
Yes.
Terry.
Post.
Yes.
Cole.
Rocelli.
Yes.
Axton.
Walsh.
Yes.
Burrows.
Herbert.
Yes.
Yes?
Chairman Hunt?
Yes.
19-0.
Okay.
All those in favor of placing it on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed, so moved unanimously.
Okay, Senate Bill 180, relative to product labeling and information guide requirements for cannabis products prohibition on the sale of hemp products containing certain levels of thc other this is the delta eight delta nine yeah right okay so yeah this is going to be part of the commission that is oversight on the bill.
So it's not needed.
Right.
Yes.
Representative Sullivan seconded by Representative Hunt moves interim study.
Do you want to speak to your motion?
or but yes we are we will be just definitely discussing this and in that at the end of the day you know it will be regulated through whatever comes out of that committee all right any more discussion on the motion all right the motion is uh interim study for SB180FN correct yes yes yes Howard.
Yes.
Vincent.
Galabro.
Yes.
Gibbs.
Spear.
Yes.
Sullivan.
Chairman.
Yes.
19 to 0.
Okay.
All those in favor of placing Senate Bill 180 on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed, so move unanimously.
And last but not least, Senate Bill 198, directing the insurance.
Two more.
Oh, I see there.
Yeah.
Okay.
This page 2.
Yeah, 3 more.
We got 3 more.
3 more.
Senate bill 198 directing the insurance department to conduct a cost study of providing coverages for certain reproductive health care.
Like to make a motion.
Okay.
ITL.
All right.
And second.
Representative Speer.
Okay.
And Representative Cole, you're recognized to speak to your motion.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
SB198, an act directing the insurance department to conduct a study providing coverage for certain reproductive health care.
The state's already done this study and given this report to this committee.
And the bottom line was it would be extremely expensive.
For that reason, I moved ATL.
and and the also the report points out because of the requirements under the affordable care act slash obamacare that um if the state if we were to pass this mandate and hope to provide it to all new hampshire citizens the state would have to pay for all individuals and small group insurance so that makes the cost of it not just the coverage expensive but now it would require a fiscal note okay any other discussion on the motion of an expedient to legislate seeing none the clerk will call the roll amon yes you yes tusick yes terry yes post yes cole yes richelli yes daxton yes walsh yes burrows Yes, yes.
Herbert.
Yes.
Howard.
Vincent.
Yes.
Walsh.
Burroughs.
Yes.
Herbert.
Clark.
Yes.
Howard.
Vincent.
Yes.
Calabro.
Gibbs.
Yes.
Spear.
Sullivan.
Yes.
Chairman Hunt.
19 to 0.
Okay, 19 to 0.
All those in favor of placing on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed?
The move is.
Okay.
Page 2.
All right.
Wait a minute, because I need two more sheets.
Let me see if they're in here.
Page 2.
Okay.
All set.
All right.
Senate Bill 201 relative to resale of event tickets.
I'd like to make a motion.
Okay.
I'd like to move interim study on this bill.
Interim study.
That's fine.
Do you want me to speak to it?
Yes, please.
Okay.
The reason I'm, I know that we had concerns about the enforceability of this bill, but since then, the Senate has been working with the Attorney General's office who believe that there are some things that can be done under the Consumer Protection Act.
So I think it behooves us to put this on interim study and take a look at at what they've come up with okay the pending motion is interim study any discussion on the motion all right see none the clerk will call the roll Ammon yes you yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes Yes.
Collabro.
Yes.
Gibbs.
Spear.
Yes.
Sullivan.
And Chairman Huck.
Yes.
19 to 0.
Okay.
All those in favor of placing on the consent calendar, please say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed, so moved unanimously.
And last but not least, relative to services provided through a primary care, 235, relative service provided through a primary care behavioral health model.
I understand that the bulletin is almost ready.
And John, are you okay with interim study?
Okay, good.
All right, so i will make the motion of interim study and second by representative burroughs and like i say the bulletin's going out and hopefully the will uh all the sides will or uh this will work and otherwise we'll see it again next year all right this is interim study on sb 235 yes damon yes mcgugh yes patusick yes terry yes post yes cole yes bachelli yes sa Yes.
Walsh?
Yes.
Burroughs?
Herbert?
Yes.
Fleur?
Howard?
Yes.
Vincent?
Calabro?
Yes.
Gibbs?
Spear?
Yes.
Sullivan?
Chairman Hunt?
Yes.
Okay, I'll...
yes yes okay all those in favor placing on the consent calendar please say aye aye aye those opposed so moved unanimously we did it and uh i want to thank my clerk for having to push all that paper.
I'm going to be here for another hour.
So that meeting you see in the calendar, disregard that.
We will not need that meeting next week.
And otherwise, all of you have a wonderful holiday season.
When do we have to have our little reports?
Okay.
Please get those in this week.
Please don't wait until the weekend.
Okay, you want them right away.
Yeah.
The sooner you get it done, the sooner you'll remember what you did.
When did we send them to you?
Just send it to me.
Okay.
Or if you send it, the carry seal, send it to me.
You'll forward it to me.
But, yeah, send it to me.
Okay.
And, or if you send it, you know, the carry seal, send it to me.
You'll forward it to me.
But, yeah, let's just, let's get them done before Friday.
Let's get them done this week, and that way the clerk will think we're, the house clerk will think we're really on top of it.
All right.
See you all, and see you in January.
See you all and see you in January.
All right.
Take care.